yeah let's talk about that you mentioned
that earlier
what the heck is mathematics and uh
okay so here's what his okay so what is
mathematics
mathematics uh sort of at a lowest level
one thinks of mathematics as you have
certain axioms
you say you know you say things like x
plus y is the same as y plus
x that's an axiom um about addition
and then you say we've got these axioms
and we and from these axioms we derive
all these theorems that fill up the
literature of mathematics the the
activity of mathematicians
is to derive all these theorems actually
the axioms and mathematics
are very small you can fit you know when
i did my new kind of science book
i fit all of the standard axioms in
mathematics on basically a page and a
half
um it's not much stuff it's like a very
simple rule
from which all of mathematics arises um
the way it works though is a little
different from the way things work
in in sort of a computation
because in mathematics what you're
interested in is a proof and the proof
says
from here you can use from this
expression for example
you can use these axioms to get to this
other expression so that proves these
two things are equal
okay so we can we can begin to see how
this is
going to work what what's going to what
happens is there are paths in meta
mathematical space
so what happens is each
two different ways to look at it you can
just look at it as a mathematical
expressions or you can look at it as
mathematical
statements postulates or something but
either way
you think of these things and they are
connected
uh by these axioms
so in other words you have some fact you
or you have some expression you apply
this axiom you get some other expression
and in general given some expression
there may be many possible
different expressions you can get you
basically build up a multi-way graph
and a proof is a path through the
multi-way graph that goes from one
thing to another thing it the path tells
you
how did you get from one thing to the
other thing it's the it's the story of
how you got from this to that
the theorem is the thing at one end is
equal to the thing at the other end
the proof is the path you go down to get
from one thing to the other you
mentioned that gadel's
incompleteness theorem is not natural it
fits naturally there how hard it is
so what happens there is that the
girdle's theorem is basically
saying that there are paths of infinite
length
that is that there's no upper bound if
you know these two things you say i'm
trying to get from here to here
how long do i have to go you say well
i've looked at all the paths of length
10.
somebody says that's not good enough
that path might be of length a billion
and and you there's no upper bound on
how long that path is and that's that's
what leads to the incompleteness theorem
so i mean the the thing that is kind of
an emerging
idea is you can start asking what's the
analog of einstein's equations in meta
mathematical space
what's the analog of a black hole in
matter mathematical space
what's the whole potential yeah it's
fascinating to model all the mathematics
well so here's is what it is this is
mathematics in bulk
so human mathematicians have made a few
million theorems
they published a few million theorems
but imagine the infinite future of
mathematics apply something to
mathematics
that mathematics likes to apply to other
things take a limit
what is the limit of the infinite future
of mathematics what does it look like
what is the continuum limit of
mathematics what is the
as you just fill in more and more and
more theorems what does it look like
what does it do
how does what kinds of conclusions can
you make so for example one thing i've
just been doing
is taking euclid so euclid very
impressive he had 10 axioms
he derived 465 theorems okay
his book you know that was was the sort
of defining book of mathematics for 2000
years
um so you can actually map out and i i
actually did this
20 years ago but i've done it more
seriously now you can map out the
theorem dependency of those 465 theorems
so from the axioms you grow this graph
it's actually a multi-way graph
of how all these theorems get proved
from other theorems
and so you can ask questions about you
know well you can ask things like what's
the hardest theorem in euclid the answer
is the hardest theorem is that there are
five platonic solids
that turns out to be the hardest theorem
of nucleus that's actually his his last
theorem in all his books that's the one
what's the hardness the the distance you
have to travel yeah let's say it's 33
steps from the
the longest path in the graph is 33
steps so that's the
there there's a 33-step path you have to
follow to go from the axioms
according to euclid's proofs to the
statement there are five platonic solids
so so okay so then then then the the
question is
in uh what does it mean
if you have this map okay so in a sense
this meta mathematical space
is the infrastructural space of all
possible theorems that you could prove
in mathematics
that's the geometry of meta mathematics
there's also the geography
of mathematics that is where did people
choose to live
right in space and that's what for
example in exploring the sort of
empirical matter mathematics is
euclidean
each individual like human mathematician
you can embed them into that space i
mean they they
they they represent a path the little
things they do maybe a set of paths
right
you